[Applause]
hi everybody thank you for coming my
name is hana van der fliss
i'm a data scientist at apollo
agriculture
and this talk i won't pronounce the
title because i'm not sure whether i'm
allowed um
but this talk is a practical guide to
beijing hierarchy modeling in pi mc3 um
pi mc4 is actually out i haven't used it
yet so this is in pi mc3
um so if you want to learn about ymc4
you probably should talk to thomas
um
so this is a practical guide because
i studied statistics um but i only had
frequent statistics machine learning
i learned how to code and then when i
started this job slightly over a year
ago my manager who's actually in the
room right now
made me do bayesian statistics
so i get on the internet and try to
learn basic statistics and it was hard
so
this talk is for everybody who didn't
study math who doesn't know exactly what
mcmc sampling is who doesn't really know
what a conjugate prior is
but still wants to do bayesian
statistics so what is the minimum you
need to know
um
so i'm going to go through a real world
example that i encountered during my job
so i tell you a little bit more of what
i do
i work at apollo agriculture it's a
fintech
slash agrotech company
um so when we started our mission was to
help
smallholder farmers become more
profitable
so we would give them good quality
inputs which is not always a guarantee
in sub-saharan africa
training insurance access to the market
but quickly we found out that
the biggest bottleneck for smaller
farmers was to get access to capital so
what what our main product is now is
that we
give farmers a loan not in terms of
money but we give them seeds and
fertilizer uh to plant the next season
with
and after they harvest they sell make a
lot of profit and pay us back and have
their own share
right so the real world example that i'm
going to talk to you about is predicting
yield
by the way these are all pictures i took
myself in kenya
i thought they were beautiful so i
wanted to share with you
um
so
when you try
when we try to predict yield we use data
that we collect in
our application survey so when a farmer
applies to our loan
we call them and we ask them some
questions so we gather some data
we ask them for example about their last
season
so this is only about may so we will ask
them how many bags of mace did you
harvest last year and then we normalized
that per acre
and we have a bunch of predictor
variables so we can use
for example which seeds and fertilizer
they used
what is their prior experience with
farming some demographic data
and their county so where they are
this model seems to predict pretty
accurately however
when we do some sanity checks we see
that there are regional clusters of high
yields in a given season
so for example a county washing issue
will have really high yields
and county ambulance had really low
yields now
these clusters are not
consistent year over year so maybe in
the first year um this was the
distribution of the yields but in the
next year and boumera actually had
really good yields
um so if we were to use that
black box machine learning model we
didn't do this sanity checks um
we might be surprised the next year
um
this has probably something to do with
rains like we're talking about maze
yields here and the rains are very
unpredictable especially now with
climate change
so they change year over year
even if we excluded
county or region as a variable in the
model the model still
predicted way higher yields for some
counties than for others so it found a
way to still represent this regionality
so this is an example of hierarchical
data
so hierarchical data has something to do
with the the way
your data are gathered usually
so sometimes you have different data
sets studying the same thing but they
come from different studies so the
hierarchical layer would be
the study
in this example the county is the
hierarchical layer so we expect
farmers within one county to be more
correlated to each other than a farmer
outside of the county
so when you work with hierarchical data
you have a couple of options
so
you can pull the data together
put everything in a big
chunk of data and you can basically
ignore that
there is hierarchy
it's not always a good idea because you
neglect important information that you
do have
and as you saw in my example sometimes
the the model will find out
that there is this hierarchical
structure
you can do an unpooled model which means
that you
make in my example that would be
30 different models for all the 30
counties that we serve
and make it so make a different model
per county
this also has a lot of downsides
in our example that would be 30 models
which is a lot of work
some groups also might have very small
sample sizes and you're not learning
maximally from the data that you have
so in hierarchical data usually you have
some shared parameters
over counties
like the effect of
your prior experience with farming on
your yield it's probably shared across
counties and then there are some
distinct effects within a county that
vary county by county like the effect of
rain
um
so the other option you have is the
hierarchical model
which is the focus of my talk and it's
kind of a mixing of the two
so in a hierarchical model you can
estimate to what extent
groups
look are actually pulled versus
different but you can also control to
what extent you want them to be pulled
or different
so you can
scale the group means towards the
overall mean
to make them look more similar
the downside of the hierarchical model
is that it's pretty complex
so i'm going to show you the simplest
way to start getting into this super
powerful technique
we're going to do this with real world
data so again we're talking about maze
shields i only use three variables here
for simplicity
so in the county
variable i have people's county then the
maze yield is bags of maze per acre and
then i have a boolean variable whether
you used hybrid seeds or not now if
you're not an agronomist i'm not either
i'm going to tell you the basic thing so
hybrid seeds usually have a positive
effect on yield
which we see in our data
so the farmers in our data set that use
hybrid seeds have an average of 12
something bags of mates per acre and the
farmers that didn't use hybrid seeds
have an average of around eight
then more descriptive statistics
uh the red bars here uh only had one
observation so it didn't really make
sense to plot uh an error bar
but here we have all the counties
ordered on
yield and on the y-axis you can see the
yields so what i'm trying to show here
is the huge differences in yields per
county
and because of some small sample sizes i
plotted the error bars on there
um so as you may know we're going to do
all of this in the bayesian framework
why um
well for one it allows you to
incorporate prior knowledge
we have a bunch of really smart
agronomists at apollo and so they know
what our normal yields for smallholder
farmers to get
we know that the yield can be negative
so we can incorporate all of this
knowledge to get more statistical power
and the second thing
maybe most important thing that uh the
bayesian donation framework allows us to
do
is that we can model the outcome in
terms of a probability distribution
so
in frequent statistics we usually uh
work with maximum likelihood and we get
this one
estimate out of our model that we're
interested in so in my example the
parameter we're interested in might be
the effect of hybrid seeds on your yield
with frequency sets we will get
one estimate with base in the bayesian
framework we get a whole probability
distribution which means that you
directly quantify
your uncertainty and which also means
that if there are some
really unlikely values in your tales but
they are really crucial or dangerous or
expensive for the business you want to
know them
um
okay so
how do we do bayesian data analysis this
is from andrew gellman's book
i see i forgot to reference but now you
know
the bayesian data analysis
is basically three
steps
the first step might be the hardest one
so it's setting up the full probability
model
so in bayesian statistics everything
uh has a probability distribution so
there are priors there's your likelihood
or observed data and there's your
posterior they all have a probability
distribution that you need to think
about
and you need to set values for your
priors which i will come back to later
and you need to say what are the
relationship between all of these
probability distributions
but no worries because
you can just go through all the steps
and then do it again if the model
doesn't fit
so
we go to step two we calculate the and
interpret the posterior distribution
so this is the parameter you're
interested in so
in my example maybe the effect of hybrid
seeds on yields so we calculate the
distribution
and the expected value and what is the
confidence interval around that value
and this is all conditional of course on
our prior and our observed data
and then we evaluate model fit so
the this step is actually two steps um
so
we want to evaluate whether the model
converged um
and we want to evaluate whether the
model seems to fit our data does it
explain our variance does it make sense
and then if it doesn't you just go back
to step one
so we're going to do all of this in pi
mc3
so pi mc3
gives you this very intuitive syntax to
describe your data generating process
and i put that on the bottom so
when i
put some code examples up there you know
that pm
is the bimc3 package
right so
some more prerequisites
so my data is called data
and i save a couple of things in a
separate variable so i have my counties
that's a list with strings of all the
county names of length 30 and counties
is an integer
that's
30.
then there's a county lookup is a
dictionary from the county string to the
integer
then
[Music]
yeah then these below here are all of
length 110 789 that's the length of my
data um so for every
person in the data set what is their
county what is their yield and did they
use hybrid seeds or not so hybrid seeds
is a boolean where
but i turn it into an integer so the one
means that you use hybrid seeds
okay
um so we're going to start with a pooled
model so that i can uh ease into the
code and make it more complex from there
uh that is i guess my first practical
tip start as simple as possible
and
work up from there because it can get
pretty confusing
so
this is what the code looks like
so the pm as i said is prime c3 so you
put everything kind of in this model
container that is why you use the with
statement
and then my my second tip would be uh
but this is very personal um
go from the bottom up
so i like to look at what is my why
which in this case is maze yields and
what is its distribution and then i know
i see it's a normal distribution well i
defined that it's a normal distribution
with mu and sigma and then i go up what
are my mu and sigma
um right so i'm going to look at this a
little more later
but
this
bottom
argument
pm.model 2 graphis gives me this
beautiful plot that i butchered with
colors
so this is step one setting up the
probability model uh on the left i
colored everything that is my observed
data um
just for for clarity and then i gave
some labels to the numbers so my
observations and
hybrid seeds are not our receipts so the
observed data is on the left and then
the priors are on the right
so i'm starting with the observed data
so i have to choose a distribution for
my observed data you can already see
here that i chose a normal distribution
but then when we go back to the codes
you see that i put in observed is log
underscore maze yield
so
why did i do that
um
choosing distributions
so uh when i
start choosing distributions i see a lot
of people talk about conjugate priors
and i was like what is a conjugate prior
so i found this um really
helpful question
um that could have been written by me
honestly um and the answer to that was
basically
uh the conjugate prior has something to
do with distribution families so what we
do in patient stats is we multiply the
prior with the likelihood and we get out
the posterior distribution so depending
on the distribution family
the posterior distribution has a certain
distribution so if your prior is
gaussian which is the normal
distribution and your likelihood is
gaussian your posterior will be gaussian
so
we want gaussian also i put this uh blog
post in here that's really nice it has
for every prior and likelihood
combination it will tell you what your
posterior will be so you don't have to
do the math by hand
right so
this is what my data looked like and as
you can see it can't go below zero
because it's the yields and it has a
long
right tail so i think
log distribution so i take the log of
that and i get this
kind of normal distribution uh that's
the piece of code that i used to do that
i added 0.1 to it because you can't take
the log of zero
right um so now i need to set my priors
uh
so what are priors um priors basically
express our knowledge and also our
uncertainty about theta
theta is the parameter we're interested
in so it's the effect of hybrid seeds on
the yields
um and it's
usually based on domain knowledge or on
previous research
um or you can google things and then
come up with numbers that
that makes sense to you um so the prior
distribution should probably include all
plausible values of theta um but it
doesn't necessarily need to be
concentrated around the true value
because the prior distribution is not
the only thing we work with
we also have a ton of observed data
so
the plausible values of theta for me
in
because this theta is the mean of yield
uh that changes that changes the
situation a little bit so what i know
from maze what i heard from from my
colleagues uh the yields can't be
negative that's one
um for small older farmers in kenya
they're they can be zero unfortunately
um they can maybe be 30 bags of mace per
acre but because these are means
uh they won't be zero
that would be very unfortunate so the
probability that their zero is really
really really low to maybe non-existent
so i think the probability distribution
is somewhere between 5 and
20.
we're working with logs
i'm not really good at thinking in log
distributions
so i think that probably my
prior distribution should be centered
around 10 so i take the log of 10 i make
this distribution and it looks about
right
so in my case i used domain knowledge
to make this prior distribution
and then i need to set a prior for my
sigma
so
there's a couple of options for one
the sigma can't be negative um so it
needs to be like half couchy or half
normal
at least it needs to be cut off at zero
half couchi is a weekly informative
prior
usually it's easy to look up some blog
posts or look in some of andrew
gellman's books where there are lists of
weekly informative priors and you can
pick one of those and try it out
so i gave it the scale parameter one i
plotted it and looked at it and
looks good to me
so this is the probability model
for the simplest model that there is
[Music]
so what i'm doing here
is i estimate two thetas
uh you can see that here
theta is
a seeds index heat is has the dimensions
two because there's a
hybrid seed and a non-hybrid seed
and you can see that here in dimensions
so i'm getting two
posterior distributions back
[Music]
so now i'm gonna calculate them and
step two and three come at the same time
so to interpret the posterior
distribution so what i see here on the
x-axis is hybrid seats is true or false
so these
um
this is my expected value this blue line
um so the expected value
uh
the expected yield when you have hybrid
seats or not of hybrid seats um
it's it's expected to be a positive
influence so having hybrid seeds leads
to higher yields that makes sense
then the big yellow band is the expected
distribution of your observations
and the blue dots are my actual
observations so to evaluate model fit
what i immediately think is well a lot
of my observations are outside the
expected distribution
um so it seems like
uh having hybrid seats or not explains
quite a lot of variants
which is indicated by this big yellow
band but also
doesn't explain all of this variance
and when we think back about
the histograms that i showed in the
beginning
we know that the county uh makes a
really big difference um
in yields so
maybe we can explain some more variance
by including our county variable
so that brings us to the unpooled model
so the unpooled model again is where you
split your data set in this case in 30
different little data sets you make 30
models but we can do it in one go so
this is what it will look like
so what changed i added
the county here so for every person now
i know what their yield is whether they
use a hybrid seat or not
and what their county is
and i'm going to estimate not 2 thetas
but 30 times 2 thetas
so i will get the hybrid seed is true
and the hybrid seeds is false
posterior distribution
for every county
important to note is again that if i am
calculating this for county washing
issue for example
i don't know anything about the other
counties or the observations in the
other counties so they're truly
independent
uh
models or possibly distributions
um this is what changed in code uh so i
gave it just an extra dimension which
makes it which makes it 30 times two and
you can see the same thing here right
now i have county and hybrid seeds
so this is the setting up the
probability model for for this model
then step two and three come at the same
time again so to interpret the posterior
distribution
we have to interpret 60 posterior so
that's a lot of work
so i'm immediately going to
evaluate the model fit so i just plotted
six counties here
these
points are the expected value the thick
line is the 94
hci around that value and the thin line
is the expected distribution of
observations
so i only put six counties in here
so there are counties where the yield
with hybrid seeds is actually lower than
without hybrid seeds so this is this is
an example
you can see from from the uh big
interval that it probably doesn't have a
lot of observations in there so there's
a lot of uncertainty
however this is this is pretty dumb
because we know
that hybrid seeds almost always or
always has a positive effect on your
yields we have the data to prove it but
we're not using it we're only using the
data from this one group and so for this
group we would say
the effect of hybrid seeds is negative
the other problem is there are counties
where the difference in yield
between hybrid and non-hybrid is way
higher than in other groups so as you
can see the difference between those
estimates
is pretty big while in a lot of other
counties it's it's much smaller
again we're not using our data maximally
we know from other counties that the
difference is not that big
but we're not using that information and
then the third more obvious problem is
that we have a lot and there are a lot
more
if we look at all the counties we have a
lot of counties with big
uncertainty due to small sample size but
we have a big sample size
right so that brings us to the
hierarchical model
um
so we start with step one again we set
up the full probability model now it
became really complex all of a sudden
right so i have this normal distribution
again
and now three things are pointing arrows
to there so what is my mu and my sigma
to me it's not immediately apparent from
here so i will show you in the next
slide what it looks like in in code
but what i want to show here is that
in this model what i'm doing
is i'm estimating 30 different
intercepts
so they basically mean what is a
county's base yields without using
hybrid seat and that is a different
value for each county
um
and they come from the same normal
distribution with uh the mu and the
sigma
um so
what that looks like in code
here you see the formula that i was
referring to so now you know how those
three arrows relate to each other so we
have 30 different intercepts so
depending on which county you're in
you have your intercept and then we have
one common slope
we don't have to have one common slope
we could have 30 different slopes but it
would become a little complex for this
presentation so we have one common slope
um
right and then the other thing that i
want to show is
this sigma
is basically your control parameter so
if this sigma was zero
that would mean
that all the intercepts are the same
there's no difference between counties
so we could tell the model that we want
that
if this sigma approaches infinity
that means that all the county
intercepts are totally unrelated
um so you could control this parameter
uh for now i wanted to set a kind of
reasonable value to let the model
estimate that parameter for itself
um
yes so we're gonna
go to the next step um step two
interpreter posterior distribution so
i'm only gonna interpret the posterior
for b which is my common slope
[Music]
right so we see this is what a posterior
distribution looks like
we see a value 0.44 it doesn't really
mean that much to me
but the first thing that i see
is that the
94 hdi is pretty narrow so we're
relatively confident in this in this
number uh and it's positive so the
effect of hybrid seeds is positive
um and then because this is on a log
distribution we uh take the exponential
0.44 and we get 1.6
so 1.6 is a relative effect so the way
you need to interpret that is
depending on your county you have an
intercept
so say that my intercept is
five bags of maize so without using
hybrid seeds i will probably get five
bags of mace per acre then i multiply
that number by 1.6 to get the estimate
for when i do use hybrid seeds
so to get the actual numbers of
estimated yields we need to do a
posterior predictive check which then
looks like this
so we have 30 different estimates for
the intercept
some of them way lower than others
and
then we have we plot the slope in here
so it's basically the intercept
multiplied by 1.6 to get the
hybrid seats is true
so to take a step back
i want to compare the three uh methods
that we have
um
so the the three methods no pooling
complete pooling and the hierarchical
model
up top you see two counties that have
uh only a couple of observations so the
left county um thoraconethy only has two
observations and so that means that in
the no pooling one uh it will just kind
of draw a line from observation one to
observation two
um
the complete pooling line is the same
for every plot because county is not
taking into account
so what you usually see
is that
the hierarchical model line
is kind of an in-between between
complete pooling and a no-pulling
version because it shrinks your group
mean towards
the so the county mean towards the
country mean
so this is a nice visualization to see
that effect
and as you can see for counties that
have more observations the difference
between
no pooling and a hierarchical model is
not that big so the more observations
you have the more the model will trust
on the group mean
and that obviously also depends on the
priors you set
um
so what else can we do to make this more
complex and
make a better model
we can add varying slopes
so
a different slope per county and we can
add correlations between intercepts and
slopes
so that would mean which i think is a
pretty reasonable statement is
uh for example if you have really
unfertile ground you can put a hybrid
seed in there but it's still not going
to give you a lot of maize
so we probably think that if your
intercept is really low your slope is
also lower and if your intercept is
really high your slope
might also be higher i didn't test this
it's just speculation so we could do
that
we can add more predictor variables to
explain for more variants add more
complexity in the model
if we have data from multiple seasons we
can add another hierarchical layer for
season
we could estimate what the extent to
what extent
yields actually differ
season two season but also
uh how that differs per per county so in
some counties you might see really big
seasonal effects and in some counties we
don't
um so these are all possibilities
um
these are my uh
some of my references i don't think this
is really complete
on top is the the stack exchange
question that i showed
that i think also links to a blog post
that shows prior and uh
posterioris or like the what are the
conjugate priors for
uh certain likelihoods
um
this is the docs from imc uh an example
of uh with radon estimates where they go
through a hierarchical model it kind of
uh goes through the same steps as i did
well that's no coincidence because i
followed the blog post um
this is thomas's website it was right
there um he has a lot of super useful
blog posts on uh bayesian modeling and
bayesian hierarchical modeling that i
use a lot and this training i didn't
actually do i heard about it on friday
in the workshop in chris's workshop
on patient modeling so it looks really
interesting you might want to do it
we're hiring do you have any questions
thank you very much hannah that was
lovely and clear yes we do have time for
questions who has a question for hannah
lovely i'll start at the frontier there
you go
so thank you very much for the
presentation um i was wondering if you
think that
adding correlate spatial correlation
between the different counties could
have been something that might have
helped the estimation in this case
yeah i think i actually um
talked about that with thomas on friday
um the hard thing about the spatial
correlations
is that sometimes they're uh or at least
in kenya because of um mountain ranges
usually uh counties that are adjacent to
each other have similar range but then
all of a sudden there can be this like
cut off and then people on one side of
the mountain have the rain and on the
other side they don't so i think it's
completely possible it's just a little
harder than it did at first sight yeah
another question there we go
yeah thank you very much it's really
interesting um i've got a lot of
questions but
only one forward um
um why did you not maybe approach it
using some
experimentation like in terms of
understanding the this hybrid seed or
not or did you maybe try um and it
wasn't successful
um so you mean like putting people in
different groups and giving them hybrid
seeds or not correct so i think the the
nice thing about uh
bayesian hierarchy modeling is that
obviously it's the best to do
experimentation but it is also the most
expensive and the hardest
and so even though um i didn't make
experimental groups and this is all
observed data um because we have these
uh
uncertainty estimates um i think it
gives a very good estimate of what could
have happened when you did do an
experiment so it's kind of like if you
can't if you're not if you don't live in
the ideal world
um how can you still make sense of your
data
i love you one last question we'll take
over here
thank you very much for the presentation
uh i would like to know how do you
decide between what distributions to use
because here in the case you use cauchy
but i can assume that sometimes you
might want to add the time in the time
component so maybe poisson might be a
little bit more appropriate when would
you use one over the other um is this
just by experimenting or is it something
that as an intuition of seeing the data
yeah um so i think
for
observed data you usually think about
what is the the structure of your data
um so um if your outcome would be like
or or if your observed data would be
this experiment with true or false and
or or accounts you might use binomial
data or poisson uh data distribution
um since you mentioned the half calci
distribution this is actually something
i struggle with uh giving the sigma a
distribution and i heard from thomas
that the half couch is actually not that
um useful to use any or any more maybe
because it has a long tail so it's
harder to estimate so he uses a half
normal distribution
so for the sigma the only things that i
know is that i want it to be positive
and what what do i think are like
probable values but apparently having a
really long tail makes estimation time
really long and sometimes then models
don't converge
um so it's actually good that you asked
should have probably said that
lovely well thank you ever so much for
your questions hannah are you around
later to answer more questions people
have them perfect another round of
applause for our speaker